we're in the throes of Scilly season
those delightful summer months when the
mainstream media focus on frivolous news
stories while everybody vacations here
in the United States where there's no
difference between the mainstream media
and the Democrat Party it's lefty
politicians and activists leading the
silly season a gay male congressman
rants about tampons a transgender
left-wing activist calls the American
flag racist and so not to be outdone CNN
runs this shocked story of that one time
president Trump politely asked for a
coca-cola they've got him now or they've
got him now unreported as Democrats fizz
over silly season president Trump
successfully negotiates a better trade
deal with the EU he averts a trade war
he compels NATO allies to pay their fair
share for security and demonstrably he
begins to dismantle North Korea's
nuclear weapons but tampons and
coca-cola that's the writ as the real
story isn't it tampons and coca-cola
then alley Stuckey drops by to discuss
her nefarious fake news satire of baddie
socialist Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Nolan
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to today and actually of
the gay male congressman who is focused
almost exclusively on tampons a
something that probably shouldn't
involve him too much that guy I actually
know him I've know him very well I've
known him for a long time we'll get to
that all in a second this is there's a
lot of very important stuff to cover
today before that let's talk about your
security expressvpn you if you're not
using expressvpn you should stop
whatever you're doing right now and get
it it takes two seconds and it will
protect your data do it right now do it
I'll wait I don't care I'll sit here all
day folks expressvpn expressvpn comm
slash michael mi CH AE l expr ESS VPN
comm slash michael mi CH AE l you'll get
three months free with a one-year
package it's just seven bucks a month
you can protect yourself it anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address look we've seen all of these big
tech guys testify before Congress for
the last few months and they've all
admitted that they're stealing all of
your data your data can be exposed all
of your your banking data your personal
data your whatever you've got on your
computer can be exposed by just checking
your email literally you just go you log
on you check your email and your private
information is at risk or you make an
online purchase your private information
is at risk you're being tracked by
social media sites marketing your mobile
provider your internet provider
everything get expressvpn right now
seriously it is seven bucks a month
you'll get three months free with a
one-year package just get it just don't
be stupid you're you are so vulnerable
on the internet go do it right now
I would not go on the internet without
it expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH
AE l okay back to the the great issue of
the century tampons before we load this
we're talking about Sean Patrick Maloney
he's from my home district of New York's
18th congressional district I have
worked on campaigns against this guy at
my company my political company that I
founded regularly advises candidates who
run against this guy I'm intimately
involved with him without further ado
Sean Patrick Maloney
my office recently got smacked down by
the powers that be in the house because
we had the temerity to offer feminine
hygiene products to the women who work
for me by the way a majority of my staff
is female and we have a million people
come through our office and we provide
things like paper towels or tissues or
first-aid like band-aids supplies that
people need and those are paid for by an
office budgets pretty normal stuff but
we were informed a couple days ago that
we couldn't buy tampons and we thought
that was crazy but I was supposed to
write a $37 and 16 cent check to
reimburse the house for those purchases
because they were considered
inappropriate and now the house
Administration Committee which makes all
these rules and it's controlled by the
Republicans is lying about it and saying
that's not their policy and I'm making
it up Sean Patrick Maloney ladies and
gentlemen tampons that's the big issue
it's a big issue because there's nothing
else that the Democrats can criticize
right now everything is going too well
on domestic affairs Foreign Affairs so
they have to make this stuff up and I
bring this up because I have known Shaun
Maloney since I was I don't know 21 22
he when he first ran for Congress I was
working on the campaign of the incumbent
congresswoman and so I got to see him on
the campaign trail all of the time and I
got to tell you I have never seen a
slicker politician than this guy is
there have you ever seen just from that
little video clip have you seen a smarmy
err person in Congress I don't think so
this guy talk about slick oily unctuous
New York politics this guy was staff
secretary to Bill Clinton guarding the
Oval Office door well the interns were
flitting about coming and going then he
worked as if not to be outdone he worked
for the most corrupt politicians in the
country Eliot Spitzer that a
creepy-looking former attorney general
who was governor of New York and got
caught doing really weird things with
hookers for just tens of thousands of
dollars a night really really bizarre
and sick stuff he worked for him then he
worked for another corrupt politician
David Patterson then at one point his
company I think he was advising Enron
that didn't work out very well
Benny goes down he's in con
and now he's in Congress he's at New
York's 18th congressional districts and
he this year is simultaneously running
for two offices at the same time hey you
know this is this guy's career he's
running for New York Attorney General at
the same time that he's running for
Congress in New York at New York's 18th
congressional district and he's just
he's just slick it's just all smarm and
slickness he's focusing on tampons now
because he thinks this is going to
endear him to the women voters and to
the left side of the Democrat Party he's
running against a few women for attorney
general in New York before he runs for
Congress again and so he thinks this is
going to endear him to to them tampons
are not an office product right you
don't like pens or an office product
pencils or an office product maybe you
need a tissue every now and again okay I
can sort of see that tampons are not and
he's making it out that tampons are some
extraordinarily expensive thing people
can't afford tampons tampons cost on
average 19 cents per unit it is 19 cents
a unit to have tampons yeah you know if
the argument here is that people should
have access to tampons they do have
access to tampons if the argument here
is that people should have tampons
Gok sure people should also have lunch
are you gonna buy everybody lunch people
should have dinner of you know buy
everybody dinner people should have a
house or you gonna buy everybody a house
no you can we have a free country
luckily people are so prosperous in this
country unemployment is at record lows
prosperities at rect is is at record
highs wages are increasing things are
going very very well you can afford the
19 cents for your personal products
there are a lot of personal products
that I use that I Shaun Maloney doesn't
pay for but he's just demagoguing on
this because it's silly season and this
guy is desperate for attention just like
all congressmen are they jump I just had
a congressman try to jump up in my
Twitter mention stress start a little
Twitter fight because they're all
desperate for attention there were so
many of them that they need to
distinguish themselves somehow the
reason I bring up Maloney too though is
because unlike virtually all the other
congressmen Shaun Maloney is pretty
smart he most congressmen I met her just
vacuous imbeciles
but Maloney is smart he's not a stupid
guy he is a craven crass politician all
that he's interested in is his own
ambition
you know I don't I don't remember him
raising the tampon issue when Democrats
controlled the house I don't maybe he
his office got free tampons then maybe
they didn't who knows but he's just so
crass and opportunistic I really you got
to watch this guy and it's really fun to
watch his race right now because when
politicians ambition gets the better of
them they run for two offices at the
same time you know I this happens
sometimes for president you'll have a
sitting governor or sitting congressman
or a sitting senator rather and you kind
of understand that the president you
know it's the big most important
position but when these career guys are
just jockeying for positions all they
care about is the next move because he
cuz Shaun Maloney thinks if he goes from
Congress to Attorney General then he can
go from Attorney General to governor and
then governor to president I promise you
that's the thinking in his mind but it's
just so slick and pathetic I can't
imagine that it works except we're in
silly season so it is going to work that
brings us to our next story which is the
transgender left-wing activist
Huffington Post blogger who thinks that
the American flag is now racist racist
white supremacist this is what he said
so Jerry Jones the owner of the Dallas
Cowboys has come out finally the owner
of a football team he said players have
to stand for the national anthem they
don't get to take in me they don't get
to sit it out they don't get to go do
jumping jacks down the street they don't
get to go buy a sandwich they stand toes
on the line for the national anthem this
is enough to make me a Cowboys fan I'm
gonna become like Chris Christie you
know a native New Yorker New Jersey you
know kind of going over and becoming a
Cowboys fan because that this is
American this is a wonderful thing you
should have to stand for the pledge of
allegiance when you're playing football
simple as that
so this guy a Charles climber who's now
he's transgender so now he goes by
Charlotte climber radical left-wing
activist blogger on The Huffington Post
he he responds to this he says quote I
was raised in Texas
I've always loved football I've been a
lifelong Cowboys fan and I will never
again watch a Cowboys game so long as
Jerry Jones's racist white supremacist
pandering took us is the owner of the
team his conduct is hate
cowardly and embarrassing oh and what is
that conduct respecting the flag
that's what's hateful now that's
rightful racist
it's like cory booker this reminds me of
cory booker who says if you put a
regular normal judge on the court you're
complicit in evil and you're a satan and
it's evil it's a moral moment how
exhausting it must be to be on the Left
how utterly exhausting it must be to
have everything because you can't just
stop you can't stay at your regular
normal stasis level of outrage you have
to get progressively more outraged so
now the suggestion is that respecting
the flag is racism white supremacism
hateful cowardice blah blah blah that
voting for a judge which our elected
representatives have done for the whole
history of the country
that's complicity and evil and Satan and
Brora
oh how exhausting I will point out
though cuz some conservatives get this
wrong this free speech issue on the flag
protests at the national anthem they say
well if we make the players in the NFL
stand for the American flag then we're
just like the anti free speech people
they should have their free speech and
free speech and free right okay right
right right uh NFL players professional
athletes do not have the right to do
whatever they want on national
television they don't have the right to
break the rules athletes play a game
that has rules one of the rules of the
NFL is to stand and respect the national
anthem and to respect the flag one of
the rules at the Dallas Cowboys is that
you don't get to disrespect the flag
that's the rules the NFL players don't
have the right to go onto the field and
play baseball that would be but it's
their free speech what if they want to
play baseball it's a free country no
they don't get to play baseball they
have to do and it's and by the way
sports are an entertainment event it's a
TV show the NFL and it's at its core is
a TV show right that's where virtually
everybody who watches football watches
it it's on TV and a TV actor does not
have his free speech rights trampled on
because the director makes him read from
a script that's not but I want to say
what I want to say you
not respecting my free speech no there's
a script because it's a TV show you die
you can't that's not what free speech is
so I think conservatives get this wrong
a little bit you have to respect the
flag the other reason you have to
respect the flag is that it's the the
flag is the symbol of the country in the
country gives you your right to free
speech
it's an undercuts itself if you protest
the country you're protesting your right
to free speech it's a house divided
against itself as Chesterton said
there's a thought that stops thought and
that's the only thought that ought to be
stopped
I've got to move on but there's a lot
more you can say on that topic maybe
we'll get to it a little bit in the
mailbag now we've got to get to the most
important news story they finally CNN
The Washington Post Mashable then we've
got the big scoop which is that one time
a couple years ago get ready for I hope
you're sitting there are you sitting
down if you're if you're driving pull
over please
a couple years ago one time President
Trump
politely asked for a coca-cola he did he
did it and I'm you know that I'm a
defender of the president I he asked for
a coca-cola politely folks that's what
he did CNN here's the headline Trump
caught on tape get me a coke please
I kid you know that's a CNN Headline
that's a real headline on their website
Mashable get me a coke please people are
losing it over this moment in the leaked
Trump tape no they're not I didn't read
the whole article they're not I'm
willing to bet anything they're not
Newsweek get me a coke please people are
losing it over this moment in the trade
seems repeated doesn't that seem like a
similar story I know that nobody's
losing it yes for Coke politely this is
this is really how you know they're
desperate they can't hit them on
anything they tried to hit him on
tariffs that's over we'll get to that in
one second on the Coke in in the tape in
the big crazy bombshell tape at one
point stalking in : and then he says can
you get me a coke please - assuming I
assume it's his assistant outside this
is this is a good example because what
the media do is they take little jokes
we'll talk to Allie Stuckey about this
they take little jokes and they
create take it seriously that bring it
into a scandal or they take an offhanded
comment which is nothing like asking for
a coke they try to make that into a
story because if you see a news headline
you assume there is a story you would
just assume so it said if it's in a news
headline you'd think there's a news
story but there isn't and in the the
most obvious the most absurd version of
this I've seen in the last week at least
is it get me a coke please
the other thing by the way I meant to
point this out yesterday when you listen
to that trump Cohan tape it it sounds
like a David Mamet play I didn't realize
how good a playwright David Mamet is
he's the guy who wrote Glengarry Glen
Ross until I heard that tape but it does
sound like it goes oh well we're not
talking are we talking mic nah we're not
we're speaking whispers it a and get the
good and the check and right and this is
get me a coke please it's one of these
just throw off things they're trying to
make it into a crazy story meanwhile
meanwhile all of this is going on the
tampons and the and the coke and the
flag is a racist or whatever meanwhile
here's President Trump and the
Commissioner of the EU here he is
so we had a big day very big we met
right here at the White House to launch
a new phase in the relationship between
the United States and the European Union
a phase of close friendship of strong
trade relations in which both of us will
win this is why we agreed today first of
all to work together toward zero tariffs
zero non-tariff barriers and zero
subsidies on non auto industrial goods
thank you thank you thank you we will
also work to reduce barriers and
increase trade and services chemicals
pharmaceuticals medical products as well
as soybeans soybeans is a big deal and
the European Union is going to start
almost immediately to buy a lot of
soybeans they're a tremendous market by
a lot of soybeans from our farmers in
the Midwest primarily so I thank you for
that gent load he goes on by the way
there are also the
Union is going to buy more liquefied
natural gas possibly oil this is a big
hit to Russia this is what Trump had
been signaling for the last few weeks
now it says why does Europe buy their
oil and their gas from Russia they
should do it from us and you're seeing
the culmination of that in this
conference today is a huge win we have
been told now for weeks and weeks and
months and months from all the smart set
from Trump's detractors on the left and
the right that President Trump II
doesn't know what he is doing he's a
crazy person only a crazy person would
threaten tariffs on Europe only a crazy
person would threaten our allies in NATO
you know and criticize them and say they
should pay more money only a crazy
person would would negotiate with Kim
jong-un and go over and have a summit
with the leader of North Korea only a
crazy person and yet what have we seen
in the past week trade wars averted
they've come to an agreement they said
there they're just finalizing putting
the finishing touches but they've come
to an agreement no further tariffs
they're going to work to eliminate all
of the non auto tariffs that there
currently are and the EU is gonna buy
more soybeans that's good politically
and it's good for America's farmers and
they're going to buy more natural gas
and possibly oil that's strategically
quite important and another big win
politically and for for American
producers so we've been told that what
else have we been told we've heard from
the Secretary General of NATO that
whereas four years ago only three allies
the NATO allies were actually paying
their fair share what they said they
were gonna pay for defense spending they
were looking forward this year they
expect eight allies to do that I wonder
why probably perhaps let's say it's
because President Trump had the courage
to say hey guys you're not paying what
you're supposed to pay and you have to
pay how about in North Korea looking
over the Pacific right now you've got
Kim jong-un we have satellite images
demonstrating the Kim jong-un is
dismantling his nuclear program now
we've been told oh he's not going to do
it he's faking don't believe Kim it's
the worst thing ever to have the
American president meet with Kim jong-un
it's terrible it's a huge mistake
looks like it's working there there are
analysts now international intelligence
analysts saying that the sites that are
being dismantled right now launch sites
factories bomb factories production
facilities for space launchers they're
being dismantled
being ripped apart right now this is at
least a gesture of goodwill and it's a
step in the right direction I told you
last time at the summit that we were in
inning one now maybe we're in inning two
moving in the right direction
all of president Trump's critics who
said he's a crazy person only a crazy
person would do this they were proven
wrong they've been proven wrong on every
front this week and so I might just
suggest that this madman strategy of
President Trump seems to be working you
know this isn't some crazy conspiracy
theory Richard Nixon used the madman
strategy it's to appear volatile
unpredictable and and reckless willing
to you know have a credible threat of
violence both economic economic violence
military violence political violence and
he has a credible threat and it's worked
Niccolo Machiavelli wrote about this
pretty credibly in in the discourses on
Livy 500 years ago 501 years ago he said
it I'm paraphrasing but at times it's
quite helpful it's quite useful to
appear mad to appear reckless or insane
and we're seeing this work out with
President Trump I wonder when his
detractors are gonna get the message
because it's just working so
consistently and on such a large scale
you would think they'd get the message
soon but they probably won't okay we've
got to bring on speaking of the
culmination of Scilly season we've got
to bring on our very good friend Allie
Stuckey who is being accused of
spreading fake news of she created the
satire video we played it on the show a
couple days ago obvious satire making
fun of a widely seen clip of Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez on Margaret Hoover's
program and the left has pummeled Ally
they've said you're spreading fake news
you're making Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
looked like a fool Ally what do you have
to say for yourself young lady I have to
say I am so sorry I am never ever ever
going to tell a joke ever again and what
I realized is that that practice is
really only exclusively reserved to
comedic geniuses like Michelle wolf like
Samantha bee like Stephen Colbert all of
those people that are so original
compelling in their comedy
I just don't have what it takes I've
realized that I've learned my lesson and
it's only serious commentary from now on
I'm really glad to hear that because as
you know only left wingers are allowed
to make jokes conservatives are not
allowed to make jokes and and when you
make jokes I've been watching a lot of
Jimmy Kimmel recently and Michael Ian
Black and and you have to you're
supposed to not make people laugh you're
supposed to cry you're supposed to just
sit into the camera crying so you
clearly got it all wrong I gotta tell
you this this blow up from your video is
my favorite news story of the week my
great my real question on this because
the video is obvious satire you posted
it with a little winky face it's in you
know you're in different clothing it's
on a different set I mean it it is no
offense to the production I think this
is part of its charm it's a little low
production quality this was not you know
some great a selective editing and
uniformly the press attacked you they
said this is their this is an unfair
attack on Cortese my question is are the
press and the Democrats being obtuse
here intentionally misrepresenting the
video or are they really that stupid no
I think that I think that you're right
that they're misrepresenting the inner
the satire of the video and you made a
comment earlier that they take something
that they know is a joke and they blow
it up into this national scandal in
order to discredit any legitimate humor
that's in it because one number one a
conservative is not allowed to be funny
if the conservative is being funny then
it's mean but if Sasha Baron : is funny
or if he makes fun of someone on the
right then it's hilarious its comedic
genius but if the conservative does it
and it's bigoted I mean number two I
also think it lit it hid a little bit
too close to home for them because I
think it was a little bit now that I
look back difficult to distinguish
Alexandria actually making a fool of
herself in the PBS interview and us
making her make a fool of herself in a
satirical interview so I think the left
has tried really hard for the past weeks
to make us forget about that firing line
interview to cover up the fact that
Alexandria really has no earthly idea
what her own agenda is and this just hit
a little bit too close to home it was
too soon for
and I think that's why they didn't eat
this joke very well that's exactly what
I think I I think I'm not being a
conspiracy theorist when I observe that
the left and the Democrats had this real
problem which is that their superstar
girl who won this big surprise election
in Queens looked like an absolute idiot
I mean not only did you not know
anything but she was proudly ignorant
she said oh hehehe I'm not the expert on
this simple thing I know she's got a
degree in international relations from
Boston University she as she said oh I
think people aren't comfortable with
politicians who don't know everything
she it's not that she doesn't know
everything she doesn't know anything and
I think the left and the media honed in
on this and they said shoot how are we
gonna get out of this and say oh we're
going to we found the satire video we're
gonna say it's her fault it's Ally
Stuckey's fault that Ocasio cortez looks
like an idiot on on the video they're
basically using you as the scapegoat for
why their own candidate looks foolish am
I crazy what they don't realize is that
I've got multiple emails from Democrats
from people saying look I don't like you
I don't follow you I don't agree with
anything you say but thank you for doing
that because this is not going to be the
future of my party we have a lot of
people backing away from the socialist
label and backing away from her
specifically because not only is she a
far left socialist which I think a lot
of Democrats actually imposed whether
they say it or not but she's a stupid
socialist it would be one thing if she
was smart if she was able to back up
what her beliefs are if she was able to
say well here's why I think Israel is
occupying Palestine that okay we can
deal with that but she's not even able
to do that so I've actually seen a lot
of people from the left comport and say
thank you so much for doing that but
what we see is the frontrunners for this
particularly the Millennials on the left
they just don't want to play that game
this is their sacred cow this is the
so-called future of their party and it's
not a joking matter Michael yeah no
that's that's absolutely right and I do
want to ask about the topic of the
satire video itself this this girl
doesn't know anything Alexandria Cassio
Cortes she's also a liar she
misrepresents where she comes from I
know this because I come from
almost exactly the same places that she
comes from at almost exactly the same
time so I just I know for a fact that
she's a liar and I do wonder how are
Democrats gonna going to react here you
know
socialists have relied on useful idiots
for the entire history of socialism
Lenin did Stalin did all the way right
up to Little Miss Ocasio Cortez is the
party going to embrace this leftward
lurch double down on their base try to
bring out the base for the midterms and
move it you know left of Lenin or are
they going to it were is that going to
be unsuccessful are they going to have
to go back to the center and you know
nominate Joe Manchin in 2020 or
something like that where is the party
actually headed well I think that it the
party doesn't really have a choice it's
where the people say the party is going
to go so Millennials aren't going to be
the biggest voting bloc if they do vote
once more baby boomers die starting to
be morbid but I think that they're
looking at Millennials and saying okay
these are going to be the voters what
did they care about what did they think
and unfortunately we know that a lot of
Millennials do lean to the left and a
lot of young people in general advocate
for things like free health care
coverage and free college we know that
the Democrats are trying to pass a bill
right now that demands a free two-year
Community College and we know that's
just a stepping stone into the hole for
a four-year college direction so I think
if that's any indication it looks like
even though it even though it seems like
it's on the fringe
it looks like the entirety of the
Democratic Party is going where I think
it has to go in order to attract young
voters and I think that is in the
direction of socialism yeah they don't
have the choice do they I always
wondered why Pelosi and Schumer didn't
try to work with President Trump when he
came into office President Trump is
relatively unknown for a Republican
president I felt they could have maybe
worked with him but but their base
wouldn't let them I mean their voters
simply had them in a corner they
couldn't work with President Trump and
this this question I have man I'll let
you go or is it wise for conservatives
to cheer on the ocasion Cortez's say
yeah guys nominate the craziest
communists you can so we can win the
next election
or is there a danger there should we
watch out because the more they nominate
these people there are 42 Democratic
socialists of America endorsed
candidates running in this cycle you
know the more that they run these
candidates the more mainstream socialist
ideas get and in the long term it might
hurt us which is it should we be happy
when they nominate these crazy lefties
or should we should we warn against them
well so I think that there's a danger
here you have people like Conor Liam
from Pennsylvania for example who came
across as a moderate who said you know
I'm gonna be middle of the aisle we kind
of praise this as saying okay this is
good maybe they're Democrats who
actually want to moderate candidate but
I think what we're going to see is that
these people that are running moderately
are actually going to rule or legislate
to the left and so I would almost rather
someone like Acacio Cortez at least come
out and say no I am far left no I am a
socialist so we can call out the
stupidity beforehand
I just don't think that there is a
moderate direction for the Democratic
Party so it's almost like whatever
opportunity that we can take to show the
stupidity of socialism the better it is
but you're right it is going to require
us fighting that much harder if we are
going to actually show the stupidity of
it or else you know we'll just be
overcome by totalitarianism like every
other generation around the world that
that's such a good point that the
question might not be here for the
Democrats between the far left and the
centrists that ship has sailed the
question is between people who are
honest about their ideological points of
view and people who hide it you know
that ocasion Cortez she might lie about
her background but she's at least honest
about her ideology whereas someone like
Connor lamb is is hiding it that's a
really good point kind of depressing but
you like to you did I heard Maxine
Waters yesterday and day before
yesterday we know how crazy she is but
she said look we are not the Socialist
Party
we're not the Socialist Party we are not
socialists so I do think that you have
baby boomers that do fear that word not
just
services but because you've got a lot of
people like Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer and Hillary Clinton that are
capitalists they like capital capitalism
is done very well by them hasn't it
exactly so I do a generational
difference there and it's just a matter
of whether Democrats are going to say
okay we have no choice but to head in
the direction of mullen meals or no
we're gonna take our party back we'll
see ya good good point all right Ally I
gotta let you go I'm very pleased though
that you have finally you know self
flagellated maiya colpa Mia culpa for
that awful deceptive deceitful fake news
all right
I'm you know great grace abounds I will
talk to you later alligator cu8 alright
we've got to say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube then we have a whole mailbag to
get to so let's let's hurry up through
that I'm always late on the mailbag or
and I will try to run through them today
if you are on daily we're calm thank you
very much you help keep the lights on
you keep leftist tears bubbling up
through my cup and there are a lot of
them these days I've got this Shaun
Maloney a female hygienic product
vintage it doesn't it's not it's not
great it's like frankly I'd go back and
you know use the james gunn vintage or
something somewhat of one from this week
but you get the left is tears tumblr
that is the most important thing sure
will you get my show Drew's show the ben
shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag which is coming up you test
questions in the conversation this is
what you want this is the thing baby go
to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with a mailbag
[Music]
let's burn through them we're getting to
all these questions today starting with
Emanuel o come o come Emmanuel hi
Michael I was wondering if you could
clarify the definition of ideology for
me what is the difference between a
system of beliefs and ideology for
example I'm a conservative and a
Catholic why or aren't they considered
ideology does it just constitute the
amount of passion one has if so where's
the line thanks so much love the show
okay this is really a tough question
actually I pulled some notes out for
this one because people misunderstand
this one a lot I've been reading a lot
of Michael Oakshott he's a great
political philosopher from Britain in
the 20th century and very few people
read him but they should read him
because he's very good I'll use his
definitions I'm stealing freely from him
uh the the conservative thought and the
Catholic Church and these things are not
ideologies they should not be ideologies
we can lean into it i ology sometimes we
can fall into ideology but we should
resist it as much as we can what is the
definition of ideologies in a great
essay called rationalism and politics
Oakshott defines ideology as the
formalized abridgement of the supposed
substratum of rational truth contained
in the tradition which is a mouthful but
I think it's a pretty good approximation
it's very formalized it's rationalized
it you can write it down in a book
another another definition he gives in a
different essay is ideologies of
vocabulary of beliefs in terms of which
to conduct political discourse so you
can know an ideology by its vocabulary
you know the left they say yes slay
folks be an ally and then we can go
adulting together and you can tell that
there's an ideological point of view
there you know ideology is it gives the
appearance of a complete system you use
the word system that's a good place to
begin it's a system you can fit it all
in a book you can put an ideology in a
book or a manifesto or a doctrine and
they say this is this is our ideology
now but you can never fit the totality
of knowledge into a book of course not
there you always hear there's some guy
you know so-and-so is street smart but
he's not book smart or is book smart but
he's not street smart someone can be
very book smart and have no idea how to
get along in the world why is that
because there are two kinds of knowledge
there's a technical knowledge which you
can write down in a book and there is
practical knowledge the knowledge that
is just it comes from your gut it comes
from the rituals that you do it comes
from the traditions that you're part of
the institutions that you're a part of
the you if you're born into it and then
grows through you as if it's in the air
you can never put that into a book you
know a good example of this I guess is a
cookbook and this is an example Oakshott
gives I can hand you a cookbook you will
not become Mario Batali because I hand
you a cookbook you will have the you'll
have some technical knowledge in there
turn the thing on to this you know use
these ingredients this is what
constitutes the this dish or whatever
but that won't make you a great cook
because there's a practical knowledge
that's required to idealogy in the
modern sense also it can really be
traced back to Machiavelli the guy who
wrote the Prince there you know where
the prince and discourses on Livy in the
prince he says here is a shortcut here's
a crib to politics here is for the new
Prince the prince who doesn't have
generations of political education
behind him here is a cheat sheet and
this will give you some ideological
doctrines that you can incorporate in to
your political leadership and you know a
lot of teenage kids they read the Prince
the first time and they say oh great now
I can be the president you know now I
can be whatever no and Machiavelli makes
this this clear - he doesn't just offer
this book and he says ok now you can go
govern the principality he says here's a
book here's some technical knowledge but
you need me he offers himself he writes
the prince in part to get himself a job
right cuz he says you need someone who
has practical knowledge to lead you
through it you know the teacher can
teach from the lecture hall but that's
that will bring some information over
but you also have internships for a
reason to work alongside a master that
he can't tell you he can't use words or
put it into a book but you just learned
by being in the practice with somebody
it's really important
ideology this is another bit from
Oakshott is not the quasi divine parent
of political activity but the earthly
stepchild the ideology comes after the
political activity it doesn't we don't
we don't
comport ourselves as we do in America we
don't we we who you know love liberty or
this or that we don't behave as we do in
America because we read a doctrine
somewhere that's not where it comes from
the doctrine comes out of the political
tradition that you have the left would
like to pretend it's all in a in a book
but when you pretend that all of
knowledge can just be fit into a book
you go totally off the charts you when
when the French Revolution is a good
example in the French Revolution they
tried to erase all of tradition they
tried to obliterate everything churches
or temples of Reason now and rip up all
the neighborhoods and have new
neighborhoods and what it leads to the
guillotine it leads to the terror
because it's just not human it's just
not where we come from another good
example of this is institutions and
traditions you'll hear conservatives who
say we don't want to be ideological
they'll say you know you've got to look
to the tradition one reason why it's
very hard to export democracy around the
world why we can't just lift up American
ideas and plant them in Iraq and expect
it to take hold overnight is because we
think the ideologue think that the the
traditions and the institutions the
Congress and the court and the this and
that are just expressions of our ideas
that we wrote down in a book somewhere
but that's not true Oh chef puts it very
well he says we do not first decide that
certain behavior is right or desirable
and then express our approval of it in
an institution our knowledge of how to
behave well is the institution in
another place with every step it has
taken away from the true sources of its
inspiration the rationalist or the
ideological character has become cruder
and more vulgar what in the 17th century
was larger poll say the art of thinking
has now become your mind and how to use
it a plan by world-famous experts for
developing a trained mind at a fraction
of the cost it's this crude vulgar
rationalism and and that you bring up
the Catholic Church this does this is
important here because a break the
beginning of rationalism in politics the
beginning of ideologies
occurred simultaneously with the
Protestant revolution and that's no
coincidence these these I this idea that
you can break away the principles and
the doctrines and just have that
floating in space without the ends
ocean without the tradition is an
essentially liberal idea it's a
rationalist idea and you see a lot of
its character in Protestantism to
varying degrees that that is why there
is a coincidence in the American
conservative tradition of Catholics
taking the lead Russell Kirk Bill
Buckley
other writers as well they they take the
lead all of these justices on the
Supreme Court because there is an an
conservative disposition to institutions
that you don't have when people just
pretend that you can have doctrines
flying up in the air it's a long answer
it's a complicated answer and I hope
that clears it up a little bit because
people abuse the word ideology and fall
into that a lot and conservatives really
shouldn't it's one of the key aspects
that separates the left from the right
when the right is at its best next
question
maybe this one will be a little easier
oh it will from Keegan have you ever
checked out the Chrome extension
millennial to snake people my favorite
Chrome extension ever I install it
secretly on every machine I use I work
in IT you might have fun with it so I
hadn't heard of this until you know 20
minutes ago or an hour ago when I read
that question briefly in my notes and
you have to get it you have to go get it
right now it's called a millennial to
snake people and what the extension does
is every time the word millennial shows
up in your browser it replaces it with
snake people so it will say you know
like you know Millennials like to eat
avocado a toast and then it would be
like the snake people like to eat
avocado to us you know ten ways you know
that you're a snake people it really is
very effective it brings the truth of
online articles and and treatises really
really well so I check it out from
Jonathan dear Michael I really enjoy
your show you were always very funny
funny how funny like I'm a clown like I
amuse you I make you laugh huh thank you
thank you for the compliment in
Wednesday's episode you discussed in
vitro fertilization and how pro-life
groups do not actively oppose in vitro
fertilization often in spite of the
indefinite freezing and selective
abortion of many embryos or fetuses
involved in it I'm a grad student in
genetics and I'm pro-life I do not
disagree in theory with in vitro
fertilization but
do disagree with the discarding of human
embryos that have been produced for this
reason I view adoption as a better
option than in-vitro fertilisation for
couples who are unable to have children
my question is do you think that
pro-life groups do not actively oppose
in vitro fertilization because it would
be unpopular among their supporters
because they're focusing on other
battles that they feel they're more
likely to win it asks two pros opposing
a Planned Parenthood or because of
another reason yeah yes all of that and
I think certainly the latter you've got
a you've got to make choices this
actually ties in with the ideology
question the pro-life movement is about
preserving life and stopping unborn
babies from being killed slaughtered on
mass a million a year or more in the
United States and so they're going to
they're gonna try to save as many babies
as they can one way if the pro-life
movement only focused on the first two
days of after fertilization after
conception you know the morning-after
pill if they've directed all of their
efforts at the morning-after pill some
of which or abort abortion drugs some or
sometimes abortion drugs and not
abortion drugs it's a little less clear
if they focused all of their efforts on
that they'd be much less successful more
babies would die every year if they
focused all of their efforts on IVF in
vitro fertilization because it discards
it creates a ton of conceived people you
know it creates a lot of fertilized
embryos and then it discards them if it
focused only on that they would many
more babies per year would die it would
be it would be much less effective
because people go to IVF because they
want to have more children it's a more
confusing issue it's a it's not as clear
it's not as clear-cut they could I be
opposing life when I'm trying to create
more life and it's much harder for that
but when you focus on a six-month-old
baby unborn baby in the womb that is so
much clearer you see its little eyes you
see its little fingers it's moving
around and the end and you see villains
who are trying to kill that baby that is
a much clearer issue and it's much
easier to win over so practically
speaking that's where the pro-life
movement should focus its efforts but we
shouldn't pretend otherwise there's
nothing about having little fingers that
makes your life sacred and not having
little fingers makes your life not
sacred and in vitro fertilization in
this all the time creates so many
embryos that are discarded and adoption
might be an answer for this but you know
don't forget if you're going to
fertilize eight embryos if you're gonna
create eight little sparks of human life
every time you do IVF that's gonna be a
lot of kids that you've got to put up
for adoption you've got a you've got to
find women surrogates who would be
willing to carry those babies to term
and I don't know that that's a really
workable solution conservatives should
be they should focus on the areas they
can win increasingly win on the pro-life
movement but don't don't pretend that
IVF is some simple bioethical problem or
that it's it doesn't pose bioethical
problems it does it poses huge bio
ethical problems and as we keep
advancing the pro-life cause
conservatives should think about that
good question
I've got time for one or two more from
Josh dear Michael owner of libs
do you believe Sarah Sanders will do us
all a favor and ban sad Jim Acosta from
the press pool and if there was a
vacancy and the daily wire were invited
who would be the best White House
correspondent and why I must disagree
with you my friend I would be furious if
Sarah Sanders banned Jim Acosta from the
press pool Jim Acosta is one of the best
characters in all of politics he's I've
by the way I've never seen him in the
same room as Will Ferrell at the same
time which does bring up some questions
it's wonderful I want Ron Burgundy to be
in that press room and Jim Acosta is
there you know Shelley mr. president but
he's great if if he were kicked out by
Sarah Sanders and the daily wire were
invited to join the press room
I would nominate Jim Acosta to be our
correspondent in the White House press
pool the guy is great and I hope he
stays on TV a lot more let's see if we
can do one or two more do we have time
one more she says okay I'll do one more
dear Michael I've heard some Catholics
say that Catholicism is incompatible
with the American Founding these critics
say that because the Constitution does
not mention Christ
the founders failed to recognize that
all power is given to Christ
this would include power over nations as
well as individuals these critics also
point out America's allegedly Masonic
roots how would you respond to these
criticisms and that's how I would
respond
come alright we're some of the founders
and framers freemasons yeah although
there was a big anti Mason movement too
I think John Quincy Adams led a big anti
Mason movement in the United States
obviously the Freemasons don't have a
lot of prestige anymore in the u.s. sure
the nation was founded in 1776 by
Protestants where it was founded in 1620
by quite zealous Protestants in Plymouth
although of course all of America was
discovered by a Catholic Christopher
Columbus a devout Catholic who said is a
book of ours and multiple prayers
constantly throughout the day and he was
you know always praying and so it was
quite Catholic I like that the actual
American founding the first moment that
we could say this is the origin is a
rather Catholic moment and you know
America is named after an Italian
Amerigo Vespucci that the name America
is an Italian name so okay you know
that's fine the Protestants obviously
were so prominent in the United States
and the I think it was Arthur
Schlessinger said that anti-catholicism
is the oldest and deepest bias in the
United States so I don't deny any of
that but I will say it's I don't think
the United States is opposed to
Catholicism in a way that revolutionary
France was opposed to Catholicism
revolutionary France killed priests you
know revolutionary France and knocked
down Catholic churches the the u.s.
didn't do that and it gets back to our
question of tradition versus ideology is
there an ideological reflection in the
American Founding of course we hold
these truths to be self-evident these
double life liberty the pursuit of
happiness sure that's ideological and
ideology is fine to reflect on what
you're already doing on occasion it
helps you see what's really going on but
America did not reject tradition
entirely built on tradition our
revolution to use the idea of Edmund
Burke was evolution not really
revolution we didn't kick every
everything apart and start from scratch
with a blank slate we kept what was good
we and we kept remained connected to
those traditions that inherent
traditionalism I think and reliance on
tradition makes America perfectly
compatible or quite compatible with the
Catholic Church and
also the observation of Alexander
Alexander of de Tocqueville as his first
name alexis de tocqueville the
observation of de Tocqueville that the
United States has these wonderful
voluntary civic institutions people just
choose to join them in the civic society
civil society not just government
organizations but you know all these
voluntary associations that's quite
compatible with Catholicism to rely on
institutions and traditions that's quite
good
is America a Catholic country I don't
think I'd go that far but is it totally
relentlessly anti-catholic no way if it
were it wouldn't have developed in the
wonderful way that it did okay that's
all I got to say goodbye
we've got great questions but sad what a
great man said go over to Daily wire and
oh by the way check out another Kingdom
because we're starting work on the
second season of another Kingdom
that's a Drew's book that he wrote it's
Drew's story that I perform all the
roles in so you can still listen to all
of season one of another Kingdom we've
got some really cool stuff planned for
season 2 which is coming up soon so go
go binge that and I'll see you on Monday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018